yes thanks to my passion for the new
protection and the sex other advisor the
organizer for giving me the opportunity
to present our work before I give my
main talker I add the wine page
yesterday about protein interaction
networks and applications and I work on
the East physical pretty interaction
studying around 2000 when the yeast two
hybrid system was used for generating
East physical pretty interactions so at
that time the yeast two hybrid system
was initially trained used to generate
others large-scale protein-protein
interactions so the first question we
ask that how do we ask me to the
fraction of true protein interactions
within the observe the interactions
because we have a lot of noise there so
we observe that for true interactions
the correlation between those
expressions about those interactive
repairs tend to be higher than those no
interact in pairs based on that idea we
built a person mixture model there to
ask me to the fraction of true
interactions there and this method is a
very very simple and the just you're
searching expression to ask me to those
fraction so on the other hand about 206
I receive an email the student oh yeah
your method is the best to ask me to
those fraction of truly interactions the
building that and I was the kind of a
quad she confused and then what's its
accountable because it's some simple
it's immediately and but after about two
or three months I saw lined paper from
tree that kinda also true that the
shelling was the part of the paper to
compare all this different method to
estimate to those reliability of those
protein-protein interaction network that
includes several different high-profile
papers from nature biotechnology pas and
some arm and the including very fancy
method like support vector machines and
random forests and they included many
different information there and it
through the independence of validation
criteria listed okay so finally they get
a weird conclusion and the method using
this gene expression this mixture model
tended to be the best using independent
criteria and they say ok sir the they
say okay sometimes simpler is better at
routing was on the on part of that paper
and I was surprised to see that one and
that's probably reality it's in our
research is that you can use too many
information sometimes whether it's a
train ride ball or not that's a big
problem so and after they did that work
on the way the second question we ask is
how do we predict protein functions
using protein-protein interaction
network we introduced the idea of
microbe random field to predict the
protein-protein interaction protein
factions based on those protein
interactions and we also integrate many
different information such as domain
information sequence information gene
expression data and sung to get a
general microbe random field theory to
predict improve infections and I
advanced I know those it's the first
song called message propagation through
predictable infections and this is also
the basic idea about how do you predict
the prioritized genes related to complex
diseases and so on after those work hbu
novel used the feeling colonel the over
the networks and try to predict in the
protein functions and there he show oh
yeah this matter is better than the
macro render field and the adverse I was
not convinced just by look at the papers
and I asked us new data to reproduce
without the family I say okay I have to
come I was configure convince that
defeating colonel is better than the
brand new field and soon since that time
I essentially just a like different
kernel and I used combine the defendant
colonel together with Markov random
field and today and we get another paper
that related that sir but it's on the
other hand it's a that paper was had the
difficult time to get published because
it's the accuracy is not really
increased compared to the defendant
colonel using the using the dependent
colonel a couch certainly on the other
hand because i like the defeating
colonel and I use that a variety of
different problems including integrating
the gene expression data and the
protein-protein interaction data so
there we use the basic idea that you
have differentially expressed genes in
the neighborhood and the day you
integrates that particular gene
expression as well as its neighborhood
and then you can predict to the
differentially expressed genes much
better and so that's why don't we call
it CGI and that's by co2 ma in 2007 and
that you integrated the gene expression
and the cooking interaction network we
compare that to the visit defeating
different kernel with the shortest
distance as well as direct neighbors and
then we show that the defendant colonel
has the best performance and the other
problem that we did is on the predicting
the IE I the package and zombie no III
it's a you can just knock out so using
III knock out and try to see the direc
talking they are force parts during the
false negatives and they may use this
idea of defeating colonel together with
the protein-protein interaction network
and vishal that's there you can just get
the true positive from the I I
experiment and again we show that the
defendant colonel had the best
performance in terms of with the rei
experiment and recently I say that
surely do also used is a sabbatical idea
of neighborhood and the cooking
interactions try to predict Erza I'm the
crisper packets and that's just
published recently last year by on the
genome biology so I think it's as you
all know that you have used different
kernel quite a lot and in private ideas
and I think it's through all those
applications i think it's different
kernel needs to be to go at the Beast of
all the the biological applications I
had been trying to promote those
different kind of the many different
city of inches and the comic relief from
mathematicians are can you
mathematically proved on that the
defendant kernel is the best and I feel
a little bit harder to do that I don't
know how do I answer that kind of person
to say the defendant colonel it's the
best for the the network related stuff i
I really don't know it i think it's why
the defendant colonel it's the best way
to solve those kind of biological
problem my basket intuition is defeating
colonel probably really capture how the
information is transmitted through the
through the network I think it's that's
probably the way at night I don't think
it's a mathematically the partner to do
that an honest of the project that gets
quite a lot of attention including
Theresa that use those render work and
the network stuff and try to year for
the pathways from the mutations to the
palate to the target and so on and so
that's it about all this related on the
random Network random walk on those
networks I'd I think it that's a part of
those our coming efforts and I'm all we
have no all this noise and this
shortcomings criticism of this network
but through all this analysis I think it
at least
convince that network is used before but
basic boundary because that is advil
heads for disease gene prioritization
and the pathways increase other problem
that is not touch down in this simple
image will also develop some mug maximal
I would approach for predicting domain
domain interactions from protein
interactions and that actually serve of
my most widely cited papers among all my
publications and so I also developed a
method for identifying network motifs in
those random networks and that's about
those networks and in the yeast not even
human ok so now let me get to my main
topic on the local similarity analysis
of time series data and applications to
metagenomes again this is a different
from the mainstream of this talk and I
think at the last minute it's probably
want to hear something not just the
disease so how this project started
actually it's a about 2005 or something
i heard to talk about those metagenomics
and then they talked about others in the
waste treatment and they are all the
different organ bland somehow and now
it's talking about system biology it's
not only just to consider ourself we
also consider all this matter gino's
different microbials and so on and then
I get the quite interested in that and
so I try to figure out who the
University of California work on this
kind of problem fortunately we have my
expert within this project this
professor Jennifer me and who have been
working on on the observatory for the
marine system for quite some time
studying the 1998 and they collect water
samples from different locations of the
world as well as
series data every monthly click the
water samples from the ocean and the day
they try to understand how the
environmental factors affect the
compensation of those communities and
also how does microbials just associate
with each other and so on and at that
time there were no next-generation
sequencing data at the available / today
using some other techniques try to
identify what kind of organism rd so
then they say okay so they have at that
time they have about 10 years data they
try to save them through what can you do
with this kind of data and how do I
study the relationship between this dip
in our lives so that's how the project
started and you can see they get this
different locations in particular it's
the Catalina Island and then they also
get outside of this Catalina Island two
different part of the world and then
they also get a different attacks and so
it's a great data set of spatial
temporal data and then we try to
understand what is going on so now the
bid's now we have 18 years of spider
data and after that we also i get
involved with the dimension of diversity
project dense they try to study how the
dianetics and also the environmental
factors and ecology that's it the just a
defect diversity of the ocean so that's
it we have a joint project together on
those kind of data analysis with the
next generation sequencing data now we
have more techniques to identify what
organisms there and we can get a more
the refined scale about the
organizations in those communities and
now we can study the similar kind of
person get to the more finer level about
those interactions between those olives
what is this time to visit is bouncy
data it's a every month occasion they
collect the pike biology co at the bell
as environmental factors and then they
catch the water and from the water you
can you give we use next-generation
sequencing data you can get the 16s gene
sequence and let's through that sequence
you can do clustering and then you get
to some called the operational taxonomy
unit and that's the code the
representation of the organism that's
the kind of data that we have so
essentially we have the abundance level
of the song called operational taxonomy
unit and for those who are not working
on ecology your justice in caracas this
is the pattern of the oculus ok and they
we just try to study the relationship
between those organisms oh you in the
temperature yeah temperature sunlight
and the song and also stop by chemical t
we measure a lot of how the water the
function properties of the water system
six station is now closed and I mean
that came not to be guaranteed that's
Kendall be but it did they get a similar
occasion but you know what are just
flows and and then see certainty to the
meta-genome a transcript in the data t
ok so these other scientific questions
that should we try to ask it's a no
let's see it's a man sitting as theta
and the day we have with the sickness
essentially it's a converse it's a
conservative gene part that you can use
this G to see what oatmeal's other
braids definitely it's a not exactly but
it's we try to beam them and then using
the six the sequence data and that's
called the peg sequence and the name
from there we try to classify those gene
sequences and the Democrats is a defend
the caster and the cluster itself each
class we call its operational talks on
me unit okay so yeah this is just as the
target until ecologist useful represent
that and the the technician of
operational taxonomy units actually is
not precise and actually there a lot of
debate how do you define operational
talks on me units they are still album
developed how do you define aunt and so
on this very large number of sequences
that how do you define that it's not
trivial because of the sequencing errors
and somehow it there are some the
earliest studies show that okay so they
catch a thousand the thousand of rare
organisms-- or to use in the ocean and
the day there is a song called
scientific hypothesis there are air
space fear and some our biosphere and so
on but later people say aria is not and
even if you put some 40 species into the
water and
you just a sequence that you can get a
hundred several hundred of the species
there but it's so again it's a define
OTO itself it's not a trivial thing but
here let's assume that the OTO is
already defined okay I'm not there is
how do you define OTO and suppose the
oto is already defined okay so now the
ODU is defined and then we catch the OTO
about this level in each community and
listen at first I mean it's I say oh is
this is the ed problem and we do this
gene expression and that is all the time
let's do correlation analysis to get a
network analysis and somehow and that's
what I thought is just the kite is so
simple and so that's what I did and then
it's tender out it's it's some of them
give you meaningful result but it is if
you look at it hard too good to
clustering and then you will see some
part of them you can you can align quite
well but some of them essentially it's
just like random and you don't see there
is a peasant there and then we try to
see what is going on there actually is
if you just look at carefully and you
see during the wintertime a lot of these
items are not abandoned at all and there
are no correlation between those
organisms in the in the winter time and
to me it's a no biology so I felt oh
yeah this is what is going on at the
first accurate i had made some mystical
i say okay summer time and actually at
the time you really see the correlation
is sometimes from march to stamp em
october and that's the time you see the
correlation and from march time I its
then you have you don't like a january
or december you don't see a lot of
correlation there and what is going on
and I say okay so at first according to
Maya my naive knowledge I saw the it's a
spring should be from generally 22 let's
do much and it should
generally the springtime and nothing
that time but actually is not right and
the family realize how am I not even now
that is really wrong and somebody it's
really meaningful that you can see the
correlation actually it's from sprint
around the March time to to october
november some time and they soon the
time during the winter time and even if
it's in the ocean you don't see anything
there it's just like our system and many
of them just a domain to there and you
don't see the correlation so they had to
give us something than to the main we
study the correlation it's probably it's
not the best way to justin use these a
pcc to just say oh yeah this is high and
then we gets the correlation and if
you're not high return to get scar
revision it's you let's think about
those to you for you are gaming a time
series data if you just look at the
correlation and the menu most appoint
are not correlated then PCA save your
network so now in that scene so it's how
do you really define the correlation
between those time dependent correlation
so that's what we really want to study
so now that's getting to two definitions
that we try to define it's a wine system
called the local Association what do we
mean by local incident if we have at all
time series data and some part of that
like in this simulated example will be
stimulated around the 20 data points and
then from the five from the person went
to the servants is we just random
simulated and from this 17 to the 20 and
we also random simulated but there are
some correlations between them only this
time interval so that's try to simulate
the point that we just seen in audio
data so the other thing that should from
biological point of view is there are
some delayed associations and so it's a
we know it's it's this factor is going
up the other factor is going in town and
somehow and so there are some delays is
instead of rustic look
pointa pointa correlations so in this
example and we see then TV do we have
this man and this may be to a time delay
and if you move according to that time
delay and then you see a high
correlation between them but if you just
purely calculates this correlation from
here then it's suggested you are not
able to find those correlations so the
scientific problem we try to do here is
try giving a time series data we try to
find such correlations that you have
maybe it's local maybe it's a
time-delayed and the vapor we don't know
where those local the hint words are and
where those delays are but it's a for
practical purposes we wanted the delay
to be just a busy a short interval if
it's too long delay and the name it just
to say okay we are not interested ok so
the knowledge essentially just to get
into the data and the now essentially
the data is in very how to and they may
have those 2 X 1 X 2 X a and the second
data is wine white wine to why I am it
out but the first thing they do that's a
statistical trick that they just normal
i dint using those drunk sins and then
we get to the good normalized and
although this is the very simple trick
that i actually need practice you will
see that this is very simple trick it
can be quite useful in practice because
if you're purely useless data a lot of
this data is the normality is not
satisfied and then you you probably
cannot detect it but it is this simple
way it's sometimes you can't get better
result ok so now with this definitely
this data you try to the mathematically
we try to find those sub interval of
length L such that you you have this one
and they start from I and study from G
here and they with those I'm and see the
study point less or equal to D D is
whatever you
find according to the biological
knowledge what you try to find what kind
of delay you are you interested and then
you try to maximize this the this score
that's essentially what we try to try to
get here and the soon my senior season
is to mine you do you say oh yeah that's
essentially it's the similar to like the
local sequence alignment and that is
exactly what would be the first thing
that we do I actually this is not a
completely new from our group actually
my crassness group will use this basic
idea to do the correlations for gene
expression data and he did this and for
this audience i think everybody notice
i'm not going to talk about it okay so
they opted with the tedious work
together with jennifer me and he liked
it and he talked about it yes and the
day he talked about it and then he he
showed that many of those people in the
community try to use this program and
the 14 3 and the day well for his
collaborators use the following question
to to us now supposing each data point
you not only just get one sample you get
a multiple sample and how what can you
gain by multiple samples actually he he
collected those kind of data and then he
tried to write a grant proposal on this
type of data and that's essentially give
us some idea about how do we do this and
this is Risa good questioning and the
Navy and we just get this and the ABC ok
so you summarize data and then we do the
bootstrap confidence interval for the
local similarity score and then we also
get to the p-values statistical
significance for this one son and all
this is speaking at the first I just
sorta okay Tiffany because the / mutant
data and the NBC that should be found
but it's it then later as a
next-generation sequencing data more
getting more and more and the day it
takes several weeks or a month to really
get these p values and the jetta said
don't do you have to solve this problem
i cannot use your program i will
use your program if you don't solve this
problem and so then I have to solve this
problem I communicated with the
mathematicians and then it's how do we
get this theoretical p value for this
local for this local similarity score
and you might say okay so the local
alignment score we have the some
Acadians great worker for the extreme
very disability why can we not use that
and the reason for why we cannot use
this the extreme value distributions
because in the local alignment there is
the condition the expected score should
be less than there and here we have the
expected score equal to 0 okay so like
people like being probably will say oh
yeah I know how to solve this problem
but for me I don't know how to solve
solve this problem and I asked her the
mathematicians how do I solve this
problem I'm only speaking it suggested
take a lot of time to understand what
I'm talking about what did he talk about
finally he give me and there that this
paper that I I really like a lot and the
feller it's about this great great
privilege stood there and he gathers
studied there was the X curtain of the
random walk biz expectation you could
there and that's kind of that they
freakin idea and they may use this idea
to get the theoretical pivot and so in
there you can see is nothing eating and
the I really appreciate this great
mathematicians to solve this problem and
the only speaking I cannot solve it by
myself even at this movement if I try to
prove myself but he is very very sick
mathematical theory to get those tasty
function and the density thank you in
the derivative of this complex function
here and after that I can just forget
those this symphony the serious to get
to the p value so animation that's right
and this this is not my MIT I mean it's
a fetish theater yeah it's fallacy but
what I did is just go from here to here
that's what I did I I mean I I'm tried
them all this finger I'm a middle man
and just to get this particle problem
and they connected a mathematical
problem and the day I did some
stimulation glad to see whether ye and
the word kind of tight we try to see it
is it okay to use this my and you might
have I'm serious stuff off with plenty
of the I mean I don't have enough time I
just say this is the ideal simulations
and try to see what should these are the
simulations for the histogram of that
local a local simulator score and this
is based on the fairness year okay
understand you can see it's not perfect
but at least for those tell
probabilities that's what I mean you
interested and that seems to be okay and
the SIA is ok i also just see what is
really you what is really Oh Kimmy's and
the soon I just say okay so if the NAP
of time point is planned here and you're
handed and I see it's what the p-values
through those theory here and also what
is assimilated p value here and then you
can see here it's here I mean what you
are really interested at these days it
probably is less than point or why or
something it's very small p-value and
you can see here it's actually it's
quite a close and the most important
thing is that this theoretical value is
conservative in the sense that
theoretical p value is a little bigger
then the then the simulate the p-value
soon so I'm a good they're Indians this
is essentially i can do a hybrid
approach and if i use this theory i can
get a p-value a cotton thread go there
it's a little bit higher than that most
of that result will be just a cut out
and the day I if I want to get a very
accurate p value I can just do
simulations on those
left the left pairs and the deaths of
the problem so I'm down and the day let
me just see if they are we have the
software and then there are some
competitions and that has nothing to do
with me and that's actually its bye-bye
drop night organize those things and
they collect a lot of those different
method and the actually is a tenner it's
the interaction data and then they may
justed to see it lets different loves to
to see what you have so that's the final
result that the thicket and I did not
generated a speaker that's from drop
knifes group understand this has just
come out from the east my channel
understand so you essentially that's a
suggesting and you can see here it's the
LSA and this is the error SI and this is
the era ese and so that's our local
similar analysis and no other message
that shows the app is accepted that is
that they say okay so you integrate
orders different matter sometimes it's
getting a little bit better result but
actually the final conclusion is our
essay actually it's doing quite a bit
and we know the the maximum information
content it's a I mean a lot of criticism
all ready for the end of my but actually
it's not a data better you some
situations okay so i think i just
stopped taking questions
when the local Association you say it's
like sequence life it's an access and no
gaps care yeah okay so the data was
collected over eight now is studying
from 1998 so in its the purpose the
whole purpose of the test it definitely
is not really designed for this study
are they they just try to study that
data those kind of stuff
it's changed changes someone to change
the symbol yeah it's a because of the
temperature is not like oh yeah yeah
yeah it's not always that much this year
is different from virtualization how
fast is it first right because it's the
area so it's this theory it's a classic
so that's about to be whatever you say
okay probably that's why I consider they
might make a contribution final question
symbol or just do you used to be so
sweet sridevi that but okay can you
repeat the question please so when you
have sequence you do have Reese yeah be
how Lydia yeah okay son okay so it's a
really depend it sit for this particular
problem three the assembly is not the
key issue because here the usually have
very short readings and the somebody the
clustering of the sequences that's the
cannon apart fix